voilà c'était donc un documentaire
exceptionnel que l'on vous doit re nos
gaillards bonsoir vous êtes sociologue
co réalisateur de ce film avec florent
massot à vos côtés florence bellivier
bonsoir vous êtes professeur de droit à
l'université de paris 10 nanterre
vous êtes président de la coalition
mondiale contre la peine de mort
également secrétaire générale adjointe
de la fédération internationale des
ligues des droits de l'homme en charge
du programme peine de mort à ma gauche
anne deysine bonsoir professeur des
universités spécialiste des questions
américaine est en fait un et enfin à vos
côtés christian charrière bournazel
vous êtes avocat jean sur ancien
bâtonnier du barreau de paris ancien
président du conseil national des
barreaux bienvenue à tous alors d'abord
ce film donc arnaud gaillard comment est
il né
il est né de l'idée en fait en gt envoyé
par l'association ensemble contre la
peine de mort dirigé une mission d'
enquête sur la peine de mort aux états
unis et par expérience pour l'avoir fait
avant dans un autre pays
je trouvais que la production de l'écrit
ne suffisait pas à parler au plus grand
nombre donc j'ai souhaité aussi pouvoir
faire un film que toutes les formes
d'écriture en fait donc comme j'avais
pas envie de le faire tout seul pardon
eh bien j'ai les faits avec florent
vassaux qui avait aussi envie de
participer à cette aventure donc on est
parti on a fait en même temps une sorte
de travail sociologique à rencontrer des
individus qui sont de près ou de loin
qu'on peut toucher par la peine de mort
aux états unis
et puis en même temps on a fait ce film
j'en profite pour dire si vous en avez
fait un livre qui est ici 1999 au coeur
des couloirs de la mort arnaud gaillard
chez max milo est ce que c'était
difficile de rencontrer les différents
personnages de votre documentaire en
fait pas tant que ça il ya souvent une
sorte de pratique assez singulière au
moins en france de critiquer les
américains pour beaucoup de choses en
tous les cas il faut leur octroyer une
qualité première majeur c'est qu'ils
sont extrêmement généreux extrêmement
généreux avec leurs discours avec le
partage de leurs idées avec la caméra
par exemple et donc ça a été plutôt
facile après on avait une carte de
journaliste ou alors moins tant que
sociologue
ça veut dire quelque chose un peu pour
eux là bas probablement plus qu'ici en
france et par conséquent on a eu assez
facilement accès y compris dans les
couleurs de la mort même s'il n'ya pas
très peu d'imagés de couleurs de la mort
dans le film et l'art en quoi ce film
vous qui êtes spécialiste de cette
question de la peine de mort en quoi ça
nourrit votre regard de sociologue
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert à
travers cette aventure mais on a
découvert ce sont les incarnations en
fait et ce film et il fonctionne comme
ça au contraire d'autres films qui déjà
très de la peine de mort aux états unis
qui souvent sont basées sur une histoire
dont on voit la suite chronologique
celui ci c'est un peu la peine de mort
est regardé comme un objet un objet
pénale et sept objets existent à travers
trois histoires trois incarnations qui
dont les personnages sont des opinions
tout à fait divergent totalement sur la
peine de mort est donc ça donne un
aspect presque vivant à cette donnée qui
touche à la mort aux états unis
ce qui est frappant notamment dès le
début du documentaire cette famille
lakers où on voit trois générations de
femmes dans ce taxi qui se dirige vers
ses couleurs de la mort pour apprendre
l'exécution de quelqu'un qui a été
condamné 25 ans en arrière
et ce qui est frappant c'est de voir la
souffrance partagée des familles des
deux côtés c'est à dire que ça fait 25
ans que cette famille vit avec le deuil
et n'arrive pas à le faire de l'autre
côté une famille c'est qu'est-ce qui
vous a c'était une volonté de montrer sa
set cette souffrance qui est de chaque
côté de la mort du vigile
c'est à dire qu'en fait la peine de mort
ou l'exécution de la peine de mort c'est
la commission d'un nouveau crime en fait
donc il va y avoir à nouveau un nouvelle
personne va décéder une nouvelle famille
ou proches vont être en deuil
il ya de nouvelles douleurs et c'est
cette scène cette histoire là et
notamment la la conférence de presse qui
suit l'exécution dit à quel point la
peine de mort ce système pénal fabrique
de la douleur là où il y avait déjà de
la douleur la peine de mort sur ajoute
de la douleur et avec avec cette espèce
de fantasme de laisser supposer qu'après
tout va beaucoup mieux
ce qui est pas forcément le cas vos
réactions sur ce documentaire florence
bellivier peut-être moi j'avais le
documentaire
quand il est sorti il y avait une
projection j'ai trouvé vraiment sens
sans flagornerie que c'était un des
meilleurs du genre parce que d'abord il
est beau ensuite voilà il ya eu cette
recherche d'équilibré de d'interviews
qui sont vraiment vous êtes vous étiez
tous les deux très neutre derrière et
puis bon en même temps il ya un mais ça
je sais pas voilà tout le monde il est
beau tout le monde est gentil mais c'est
pas du tout ça et je trouve
et ça m'a été confirmée ensuite lors de
la mission donc que mon organisation a
fait en mai dernier aux états unis en
dotant reparlera peut-être je trouve que
le documentaire met véritablement en
lumière l'extrême complexité du
phénomène aux états unis le 6 carnot
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
ça n'est pas un sujet tabou pl on en
parle on en parle les gens parlent
l'opinion publique les journaux et c'est
pas comme dans d'autres pays
donc moi je trouve que c'est un
documentaire que tout le monde devrait
voir alors on en parlait en même temps
il ya une aussi ce qu'on remarque une
réelle indifférence au dehors de ces
couloirs ce qui montre à quel point la
notion de violence aux états unis et est
tout autre et très différente de la
nôtre vous propose de réécouter un
extrait de ce professeur d'histoire des
droits de l'homme avec alperine de
webdocumentaires reserved fo a vu une
comédie easy groupe à la marque à 9 5%
au oui comme monster garbage score sauf
vaud munch with you menace
sauf qu'il est normal mais christian
charrière bournazel j'aimerais bien à
votre réaction sur cette idée de
déshumanisation des condamnés est ce que
vous partagez se sont plaints de jeu je
pense que dans le la peine de mort et la
suppression de ce que cette personne
appelée les ordures les parasites
il y a quelque chose de plus quelque
chose de religieux
je lui explique hugo 10 et le 15
septembre 1848
quand il parlait l'assemblée nationale
messieurs il ya trois choses qui sont à
dieu et qui n'appartiennent pas à
l'homme l'irrévocable l'irréparable et
indissoluble est aujourd'hui ceux qui
pensent que et vous le disiez tout à
l'heure très bien on évoquant ces deux
familles confrontés à la souffrance 25
ans après le crime
la peine de mort c'est une affaire quasi
religieuse d'effacer le crime qu'on ne
restitue pas il intègre hommes comme
disaient les romains la justice humaine
n'a pas le pouvoir de rendre la vie
d'empêcher que le lyonnais du lieu mais
l'idée que l'on supprime le criminel
fait comme si on avait dominé le crime
et il ya là quelque chose qui est de
l'essence de de les raisonner et est un
peu religieux
ce à quoi justement s'opposer hugo en
disant que ça n'appartient pas à l'homme
de détruire l'homme souvent justifiée
aux états unis pour des motifs religieux
d'ailleurs par les textes religieux
d'ancien testament notamment c'est
toutes les contradictions religieuse de
l'interprétation des textes ad oui
peut-être sur cet aspect la loi du
talion
elle est parfois justifiée comme la
personne a commis un crime donc il n'est
pas normal de
à mettre à mort mais ce qui est
intéressant donc moi aussi j'ai beaucoup
aimé le film parce que il dépasse le
côté caricatural c'est tellement facile
de jouer les grands esprits de dire ces
américains comment peuvent-ils continuer
la peine de mort et on voit bien on
devine parce que le film ne peut pas
tout couvrir que la peine de mort c'est
un phénomène extrêmement fragmenté il ya
la peine de mort imposé au niveau
fédéral et ça c'est vrai que c'est
facile de la justifier parce que les
crimes sont essentiellement le
kidnapping le terrorisme et dans la
psychose anti terroriste depuis le 11
septembre c'est très facile de justifier
la peine de mort au niveau fédéral cela
étant il ya simplement un condamné
récent qui a été condamné au niveau
fédéral et au niveau des états il ya 50
états et l'attitude est extrêmement
différente selon qu'on est dans le nord
des sprays du canada qui voit les états
qui ont aboli la peine de mort nous
qu'on est dans le sud est
là où je pense qu'il faut assister ou je
ne suis pas d'accord avec la personne
qui vient de s'exprimer dans le film
c'est que bien sûr il est facile de dire
ce sont des monstres met en scène dans
la loi d'endroits beaucoup des états de
façon indirecte quelqu'un qui n'a pas
commis un crime épouvantable peut se
retrouver passible de la peine de mort
mais en présentant ces gens comme démon
c'est facile et l'autre chose qui
apparaît bien dans le film et qui est
essentiel et qui est vraiment
caractéristique du système américain
c'est quelle frappe de façon totalement
disproportionnée et discriminatoire
les minorités donc dans le cas de la
louisiane
lita du rapport dont on parlera j'espère
beaucoup plus de noirs que la proportion
dans la population c'est du un certain
nombre de dérives du système ssl ghsr
dont on parlera dans quelques instants
je pense un autre témoin du film qui
appartient à l'administration
pénitentiaire qui parle d'un châtiment
attribué avec humanité et empathie
parler en ces mots de la peine de mort
de la mort d'un homme deux femmes aussi
cette année il ya notamment une famille
qui a été exécuté comment comprendre
c'est cette conception de la violence
qui pour le coup est très très
différente de celle que l'on peut avoir
en france puisque la peine de mort reste
une violence est ce que c'est parce que
la société américaine de par la libre
circulation des armes
la société américaine est ultra violente
donc la peine de mort finalement est une
mort propre et méritée comment comment
comprendre ça je pense qu'il faut relire
foucault il surveiller et punir il était
le premier à dire que dès l'instant où
un châtiment commencent à disparaître de
la publicité c'est que c'est qu'ils
commencent à disparaître d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les exécutions aux états
unis ne sont plus public
il ya des journalistes qui sont présents
et qu'ils doivent rendre compte lors
d'une conférence de presse de ce qui a
eu lieu au nom de la loi
mais ce n'est plus public et je crois
aussi que la constitution dit et ça fait
partie des mécanismes de disparition
d'une sentence dit que l'exécution doit
donner la mort ne doit pas faire
souffrir ce qui est un progrès
civilisationnel on peut dire que c'est
un sport et civilisationnel donc ça
permet de situer les etats-unis dans le
processus abolitionnistes il avance
comme les autres pays ont pu avancer
cela dit aujourd'hui pour que moralement
la peine de mort soit 7 ha dans cette
démocratie
elle ne doit plus en tous les cas je
suppose t entends théorie elle ne doit
pas pu apporter la violence donc on la
rapproche on rapproche le mécanisme
d'exécution de mise à mort d'un
mécanisme médicale c'est-à-dire qu'on en
andorre ont fait disparaître l'idée de
conscience pour oublier l'idée de
souffrance au moins physique vous allez
perdre totalement d'accord il ya quand
même quelque chose qui est très choquant
sur notamment ce temps à base à pourrir
en prison qui est passé qui s'assimile à
une sur certaines torture psychologique
pour les condamnés
et puis par ailleurs il ya l'anecdote de
curtis qui est ce revenant des couloirs
de la mort qui est absolument incroyable
comme témoignage et qui raconte quarts
des condamnés a voulu se suicider avec
des barbituriques et qu'on l'a réanimé
pour mieux l'exécuter ensuite influence
mais léger mais nous parlerons de
n'oublions pas que ce n'est pas si
ancien général et ce qui est très
intéressant aussi lorsque vous disiez
tout à l'heure c'était la publicité on a
oublié probablement qu'en france
l'exécution tt public jusqu'à celle de
weidemann en 1237 à versailles c'est
donc assez récent parce que qu'est-ce
que c'est que jusqu'en 1977 exécution
oui non mais c'est pas que j'étais pas
d'accord mais c'est que je trouve enfin
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans le film les
autres documentaires que j'ai pu voir
puis dans ce que j'ai pu constater par
moi-même
c'est la peine de mort c'est toujours
une violence exercée par l'état et à les
assumer comme tel point que ce soit en
iran aux états unis en france quand
c'était le cas bon c'est une violence
d'état
ce qui est frappant aux etats unis c'est
la mise en scène alors pas publics mais
il ya quand même une mise en scène et
qui n'est vie c'est ça qui la rend
acceptable pour pour le corps social
ce qui m'a énormément frappé c'est le
discours très professionnel quand les
professionnels de la mort là-bas
notamment une ancienne directrice de
prison qu'on a pu rencontrer lors de la
mission qui maintenant milite contre à
peine mans mais qui a été pendant dix
ans il me souvient son monde directrice
de la de la prison de saint quentin en
californie et elle elle peut avoir ce
discours de l'empathie au sens où
l'empathie consiste à je fais bien mon
job
oui est ce que ce n'est pas un moyen
pour elle de dormir la nuit c'est ça
exactement c'est exactement ça c'est la
mise à distance par la mise en scène
donc je dors bien la nuit puisque je
fais bien mon boulot et après d'ailleurs
quand je ne suis plus directrice de
prison
je milite à death penalty focus contre
c'est ça il ya un protocole extrêmement
précis et la seule solution pour
survivre c'est de se dire qu'en
respectant le protocole le condamné ne
souffrira pas or on sait qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux ont souffert des
choses épouvantables
que penser de cet autre témoignage du
professeur d'histoire que l'on convient
d'entendre qui explique que les méthodes
d'exécution était emprunté pour
certaines aux nazis c'est emprunter un
double échange les états unis ont été
les premiers à construire une chambre à
gaz
ils ont conçu les chambres à gaz dans
plusieurs états dans les années 20 et
dans deux et a précisément ils ont même
utilisé dans la chambre à gaz
ils utilisaient le site lombez donc donc
les nazis effectivement on emprunte
voilà ont emprunté ce système là et les
chambres à gaz étaient on était pour une
personne ou pour 2 personnes en chambre
à gaz sont encore alors existants
certains ont planté un plan emploi en
solutions secondaire si jamais les fans
ne fonctionne pas les états dans lequel
ça existe encore et c'est vrai que
quelques années après
lorsque les américains ont cherché à
voir une méthode un peu plus technique
et qui se rapprocherait donc d'où cette
idée appuyée nist de la médecine
ils ont emprunté le mécanisme qui a été
découvert par aoun a été pratiquée par
le médecin personnel d'hitler
c'est à dire l'injection létale
c'est-à-dire injecté remplir les veines
d'hommes d'un ou de plusieurs produits
dont on peut supposer au moins en
conscience que qu'ils font disparaître
l'idée de souffrances on n'en dormirais
avant de tuer c'est encore ça reste une
abstraction en ce qu'on ne connaît pas
la souffrance du mourir personne ne
connaît autour de sa table à souffrance
et mourir donc ça reste une abstraction
lessines abstraction qui permet de
pénétrer la culture et donc de pénétrer
les consciences des américains est de
faire perdurer cette sentence à peine de
mort au coeur d'une démocratie
maintenant elle est parée des atours de
la médecine pour nos auditeurs et les
téléspectateurs
je pense qu'il faut pas qu'il y ait de
confusion
ce n'est pas parce que ça fait souffrir
que la peine de mort doit être proscrite
et
même si et des procédés on était
observable chez les nazis les américains
il n'y a pas de confusion opéré entre
les deux donc je me permets de dire ça
en revanche ce qui est à mon avis le
motif le plus pertinent pour s'opposer
la peine de mort on le fait que l'état
s'arroge le droit de disposer de
l'individu y compris de sa vie ce qui
est le signe d'une dune prétentions
totalitaires et autoritaires extrême
la deuxième raison c'est l'incertitude
de la justice humaine nous ne sommes
malheureusement jamais épargné par les
erreurs judiciaires
et nous savons et la peine de mort elle
est absolu alors que la justice est
relative aux états unis vous en
parlerais plus c'est pour ça que moi
j'ai rencontré simple à la justice
relative peine relative
oui c'est vrai que dans l'évolution dont
on parlera certainement mais que l'on
note vers moins de peine de mort l'une
des raisons c'est le fait que grâce aux
tests adn on s'est rendu compte qu'un
certain nombre de personnes non non
négligeable était détenu depuis des
années dans le couloir de la mort alors
qu'ils étaient innocents et je vous
propose justement de réécouter curtis ce
fameux revenant des couloirs de la mort
qui a été innocenté après 19 ans
d'incarcération l'écoutent à houston
notre caisse de dire quelle histoire et
à un cas parmi tant d'autres c'est la
première fois que carthy ce revenu on
emmenait oui voilà on est allé chercher
chez lui et on lui a proposé avec
florent de de l'emmener devant le lieu
en fait de revoir pour la première fois
de sa vie il est libéré depuis cinq ou
six ans maintenant de revoir ce lieu où
il était enfermé pendant 18 ans et
hazard cette femme arrive c'est fou elle
arrive par hasard véritablement lancer
son père qui vient d'être incarcéré dans
une saison khl qui ailleurs elle habite
dans la région mais qui a effectivement
elle à cette histoire aussi avec la
peine de mort comme beaucoup
d'américains finalement dans le secret
de leur obole dans l'alcôve de leur
mémoire
elle est jeune et elle se souvient qu'un
de saison il ya quelques années quand
elle était petite elle est exécutée sait
bien que dans certains milieux sociaux
la peine de mort touche peut-être le
voisin tous peut-être le vieil oncle
grand père ça fait partie de la culture
elle voilà 19 ans de couleurs de la mort
innocentés par un simple test adn
c'est ce que vous disiez à l'instant la
justice relative pas motivé là en
l'occurrence falsification bling ça
c'est une des raisons de du désamour de
la peine de mort qui fort heureusement
gagne c'est qu'on se rend compte que les
procureurs n'ont pas les procureurs
fédéraux mais les procureurs des états
sont parfois extrêmement peu éthique et
ne respectent pas les règles donc là on
parle de parjure mais parfois ils
omettent de donner des éléments de
preuve à décharge à la défense alors que
le code de procédure les oblige à faire
ce type de choses et parfois
effectivement ils mentent et donc on
arrive à des condamnations sans preuve
alors comme la deuxième étape c'est un
jury et qu'il ya aussi des abus au
moment de la sélection du jury parce que
les procureurs font usage de deux types
de récusation qu'ils ont entre les mains
la récusation pour cause donc ils
doivent justifier que tel jurés ne peut
pas siéger parce qu' il serait très très
hostile à la peine de mort par exemple
mais dans certains états ils ont aussi
des atouts fabuleux c'est à dire ils ont
12 récusation qu'on appelle prix c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de
justifier il ya une affaire récemment
devant la cour suprême parce que le
procureur avait fait tomber les cinq
noir qui restait de façon à avoir un
jury entièrement blanc le dernier le
procureur ayant dit ah il a l'air un
petit peu nerveux et donc la cour
suprême a dit que ce type de
comportement mois ya eu un certain
nombre de décisions de la cour sur la
sélection du jury et c'est donc là en
théorie on devrait avoir des jurys
équilibré mais ce n'est pas le cas donc
c'est un deuxième élément qui explique
ces condamnations
et puis le troisième peut-être on en
reparlera c'est le fait que bien que le
roi le droit à un avocat soit inscrit
dans la constitution
selon les états il ya tellement peu
d'argent que d'abord ça prendrait
beaucoup de temps avant que l'inculpé
est un avocat ou le condamné dans ce
qu'on appelle les poses conviction c'est
après la condamnation est un avocat et
celui ci n'est pas toujours très
compétent
florence bellivier vous je crois que
vous revenez des états unis
les rencontres et des condamnés est
votre position sur ce système judiciaire
nous a compliqué de condamner un système
judiciaire de manière globale d'autant
qu'il est extrêmement différent du
système français est donc on risque de
commettre des erreurs
je souscris totalement à ce cas ce que
vient de dire anne deysine ce qui est
choquant c'est pour moi c'est que le
système judiciaire américain des états
faut distinguer comme tu le faisais très
bien tout à l'heure il faut le système
américain se met en contradiction avec
ses propres valeurs et nous c'est ça
qu'on a cessé de dire c'est petit
système tel qu'il fonctionne est en
contradiction avec le principe de
non-discrimination et est en
contradiction avec l'interdiction de la
torture et ça on le démontre pas à pas
elle désigne viens de le dire à propos
de la sélection du jury c'est tellement
discriminatoire ce qui est bien c'est
que en droit international il aimait
règle absolue qui enfin celui qui
maintenant est complètement entré dans
les moeurs qui est de dire est ce que
disent toujours les américains c'est on
n'a pas l'intention de discriminer on
discrimine comme ça mais c'est pas notre
intention
mais en réalité en droit international
c'est l' inverse où devait prouver que
vous n'avez pas discriminer or la
sélection du jury et discriminatoire la
question de l'avocat ensuite abouti à ce
que ce soit discriminatoire ya six fois
plus de noirs que de blancs dans les
couloirs de la mort en californie ce qui
ne correspond absolument pas à la
proportion noir blanc californie deux
fois plus en louisiane qui là encore ne
correspond pas donc voilà les faits
parlent d'eux mêmes et quand on vient
parler à ça c'est l'autre point quand on
vient en effet porter un jugement sur le
système judiciaire américain
c'est difficile à entendre ajouté je
souscris totalement ce qui était dit on
peut ajouter le fait que alors que
contrairement à ce qui se passe en
france où les procureurs toujours encore
aujourd'hui sont constitués le manque
dépendant de l'exécutif les
l'équivalent des parquetiers français
aux etats-unis sont des gens totalement
indépendant mais ils sont élus et ils
sont donc bien entendu sous le regard
permanent de leurs électeurs or on sait
les ravages que peut fair en démocratie
le souci de plaire à son électorat
justement barack obama ils en pensent
quoi la peine de mort alors il ne s'est
pas beaucoup exprimé sur la peine de
mort
mais bizarrement oui mais bon c'est
quelqu'un qui a été élu et en asie et
c'est quelqu'un de de conciliation ville
il n'a pas l'idée de loi du talion en
lui pas du tout simplement il sait très
bien que l'électorat dans sa majorité
est encore en faveur de la peine de mort
donc ils évitent de se prononcer bon il
peut un petit peu s'en sortir parce que
à cause justement du fait qu' à la peine
de mort fédéral alors c'est vrai qu'il a
un droit de grâce aussi pour les
condamnés dans les états mais ils
peuvent facilement se trouver des pistes
mais partout où la peine de mort a été
abolie l'opinion et au contre oui mais
c'est vrai qu'aux états unis concourir à
une élection quand on est juge
gouverneur district attorney c'est la
procureure et prétendre qu'on est contre
la peine de mort c'est c'est aller à
l'échec et donc récemment si on regarde
les deux ou trois dans des états qui ont
aboli la peine de mort aux états unis
parce que ça continue à abolir quasiment
tous les ans un c'est le sens de
l'histoire américaine vers l'abolition
pour autant et ces états ont aboli le
courage politique était modérée la part
des gouverneurs mais c'est juste des
personnes qui étaient en fin de mandat
qui était en fin de carrière il n'allait
pas se représenter ou merde plus de
risques voilà sept en 1981 robert
badinter a fait ce discours admirable
devant l'assemblée et les parlementaires
qui était issu de la droite et de la
gauche ont majoritairement voté
l'abolition à peine de mort contre une
population qu'ils étaient pour son
maintien
les sondages indiquaient clairement que
les français étaient pour la peine de
mort et là moi je suis très fier de ce
parlement de droite et de gauche même
s'il était majoritairement d'un côté
plutôt dose c'est pas la question qui a
su étant l'élu de la nation pour
l'imposition sauce
sujets aussi essentiels contraire à ce
qui aurait été commandée par la
démagogie et et robert badinter dit que
le président giscard d'estaing lui
n'aurait pas osé prendre cette décision
là on vient justement de personnes non
mais à quel point il y avait vraiment
une extrêmement sensible et que c'était
une promesse de campagne de françois
mitterrand et donc c'était une prise de
risque on en parle d'engagement
personnel le regard de la terre qui
avait vécu précisément l'accompagnement
jusqu à l'échafaud de bon dans son
client au monde a fait un buffet bontems
les hommages aux états unis pour autant
évolué ça dépend des états ma faim
évoluent dire que dès l'instant où
aujourd'hui on leur propose quand on
leur propose la question quand on leur
propose êtes vous pour la peine de mort
si par exemple nous avons désormais le
système d'aidé maximum security reasons
c'est à dire des prisons dont on ne
s'échappe plus parce que électrocution
lame de rasoir sur les barbelés et cdd
forteresse dont on ne s'échappe plus ça
associé à ce qu on appelle l iphone à la
parole c'est à dire la perpétuité
incompressible
alors tout d'un coup les gens disent bon
alors effectivement on n'a pas forcément
besoin de les tuer il suffit de les
garder enfermés avec certitude jusqu'à
la fin de leurs jours et là et là et là
tout d'un coup il y a la volonté ou là
où l'acceptation ça dépend si à quel
moment on pose la question c'est sur une
question assez assez tendancieuses la
question d'être vu en faveur de la peine
de mort ou pas si vous posez cette
question juste après un fait divers en
france ou ailleurs
les esprits sont ils à crb est-ce que
c'est pas une forme de torture aussi ça
de toute façon que je vais mourir de la
même façon et nous mourrons en prison
californie a constitué à cet égard un
laboratoire vraiment intéressant
novembre 2012 puisqu'il ya eu un
référendum qui pose exactement la
question qu arnaud gaillard vient
dénoncez vous voulez vous remplacer la
peine de mort par la prison à vie sans
possibilité de libération conditionnelle
et 47% qui ont dit oui et 53% qui ont
dit non et on a quoi ça veut dire que la
peine de mort a été maintenu et bon la
faire c'est jouer à cinq cent mille voix
bon donc c'était à la fois une victoire
bon et en même temps c'est très
compliqué parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont contre la prison à la perpétuité
réelle qui était absolument contre cette
loi dont qui se sont retrouvés dans un
dilemme moral terrifiant c'est toute la
compétence ne peut ajouter sur le cac
california sur le problème et
généralement c'est que la californie
curieusement qu'en france on voit comme
un état libéral lippi les gauchistes et
c'est n'est pas si libéral médecine
quand même un état beaucoup plus libéral
que le texas par exemple or le nombre de
condamnations est gigantesque mais ce
qui est intéressant c'est l'énorme écart
entre le nombre de condamnations très
élevé en plusieurs centaines et le
nombre d'exécutions très limité c'est à
dire que quelque part on peut comprendre
l'attitude de certains californien qui
sont dit c'est pas si grave de maintenir
la peine de mort dans la mesure où on ne
met pas alors que dans le texas qui est
numéro 1
le nombre de condamnations est suivi de
très près par le nombre d'exécutions
rappelons quand même que la peine de
mort n'a jamais été dissuasive partout
où elle a été appliquée ce qui lui en a
pris car j'ai pas suivi l'émission il
n'y a pas très longtemps sur la peine de
mort la radio et puis j'ai reçu des
lettres terrible gens qu'ils ont avec
eux de quoi parlez-vous la douleur la
souffrance des des personnes qui ont su
bien un crime waddle évidemment que
cette souffrance est absolument terrible
et qu'elle était incurable que rien ne
peut le pc et le fait d'être contre la
peine de mort n'injurie pas les victimes
on ne préfère pas le coupable la victime
mais c'est une question en réalité
d'extrême humilité nous sommes
interdépendants les uns des autres dans
le bien et le mal et que nous voulions
non c'est la destinée humaine que dieu
existe ou non j'en sais rien chacun
croit comme il
comme il peut mais ce qui est essentiel
c'est de reprendre conscience de cette
fragilité qui est la nôtre
le crime commis par l'état au nom de
l'état n'abolit pas le crime commis sur
les victimes et la consommation ne n'est
pas de cela comme la perpétuité ne n'est
pas une réponse adaptée les prix du thé
incompressibles il faut admettre que
celui qui a commis les actes des pires
puisse renaître à l'humain naître à
l'humain quelle est la réponse adaptée à
voir je pense des systèmes de pain
qu'ils soient beaucoup plus tournée vers
la réparation la mise à la disposition
de celui à qui on a fait du mal la
rééducation dans des dans des lieux
d'enfermement s'il faut enfermer mais
qui soit positif c'est à dire eux comme
le 17 ans espère 6 4 la confrontation
avec celui qui a été condamné et qui dit
qu'il a la haine vous dire que c'est lui
qui a été un et puis le fait
revenir à cette idée qu'il est un être
humain ayant commis des fautes il
admissible mais qui peut avoir est notre
avenir qui peut être utile un jour voilà
mais l'essai l'humanisme c'est simple il
y à aussi abattre le fantasme de un
système existerait idéalement et qui
abolira la criminalité ça n'existe pas
et je parle de ce fantasme là parce que
aux états unis il ya cette volonté là
c'est éliminer le celui qui a tué en se
disant il ne tuera plus adhérer si on
poussait loin leurs idées ce qui n'est
pas du tout le cas en pratique bien sûr
on pourrait tuer il faudrait de suite
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes sauf que faire comprendre à la
population que quel que soit le système
pénal choisi de toute façon il existera
toujours des crimes
c'est pas facile que dans des pays dans
lesquels le taux de criminalité est
archi bas est liée à la peine de mort
donc j'attends tout c'est tout ça est en
fait non corrélés au maintien soit
disant le châtiment suprême au kazoo
alors qu'en réalité ces jeunes alors on
les discours sécuritaires en france se
multiplient où certains brandissent
l'idée d'un rétablissement de la peine
de mort venant d'anciens avocats
notamment je pense par exemple à marine
le pen
que penser de ça que dire à nos
téléspectateurs
est ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui
dans un futur proche de rétablir et
c'est important mais c'est important des
passions humaines nous faisons partie
d'un conseil de l'europe et en tant que
membre du conseil de l'europe nous ne
pouvons pas avoir la peine de mort new
york en plus elles ont souscrit des pays
qui ne sont pas au sein de l'europe du
conseil de l'europe aurait effectivement
juridiquement ccc ça supposerait un
retrait de toutes les grosses de
national city communauté ne jamais
oublier que la fureur populaire où la
démagogie ou l'esprit totalitaire qui à
un moment donné pourrait germer n'a que
faire du droit établi le droit est
fragile et les contingents il est
variable et j'aimerais faire un cette
phrase formidable qui est dans le livre
de bernanos et 2 des carmélites
quand la berre prieur 10,1 à la jeune
religieuse ça n'est pas la règle qui
nous garde s'est nourrie gardons la
règle de droit c'est notamment se voir
absolument et la volée enfin l'idée de
l'abolition ne va pas de soi dans une
société c'est quelque chose qui s'éduque
l'abolition alors je pense qu'il est
plus simple quand on est dans un pays
dans lequel jamais à aucun moment quand
on se réveille le matin et qu'on écoute
la radio au petit déjeuner on n'entend
pas le journaliste dire aujourd'hui nous
allons exécuter quelqu'un parce que
c'est plus facile d'être en faveur de
l'abolition quand on n'a pas vécu dans
un pays où on tue au nom de la loi
mais pour autant la tentation d'y
revenir aussi parce que des discours
politiques un peu sale sens mais la
tentation d'y revenir et presque de
l'ordre du mauvais réflexe donc
l'abolition ne va pas de soi c'est aussi
une culture et un peu déprimant c'est
que un des motifs qui qui oeuvre en
faveur de l'abolition c'est le coup de
la peine de mort ça c'est difficile à
comprendre quand on n'a pas compris que
coûte cher de que les condamnés rester
un an en californie y en a plus de 115
ans ou 20 ans non non non non
les procès qui se tiendra et alors ce
qui coûte de l'achat de l'argent c'est
justement le fait de maintenir une
chambre spéciale pour l'exécution
et puis surtout ce sont tous les
dispositifs d'ordre juridictionnel tous
ses recours parce que dès lors qu'il ya
condamnation c'est pas fini aux états
unis à tout ce qu'on appelle les fausses
confectionnera mais dix et on devait
enfin en californie par exemple il ya
toute une cellule habeas corpus est à
dire que quand tous les recours sont
finis on peut quand même faire un
recours en habeas corpus et ensuite il y
à leurs cours en habeas corpus au niveau
fédéral et c'est ce qui explique que ça
puisse durer quinze à vingt ans et c'est
ceci qui coûte cher parce que ça veut
dire qu'il ya des avocats et une cellule
en californie sont bien une quinzaine
d'avocats à la syrie l'habeas corpus au
niveau fédéral c'est la même chose donc
ça coûte beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
certes on leur donne pas des avocats
tout de suite ils doivent les attendre
trois ou quatre ans mais c'est toute
cette organisation judiciaire même si
elles marchent mal qui coûte très cher
et il ya des américains qui sont en
train de se dire bon il ya des innocents
et beaucoup d'américains des étudiants
de fac de droit sont dans ces projets
innocence project dont on parle dans le
film le coût de la peine de mort
et puis ça vous avez entièrement raison
de lire les politiciens deviennent
courageux quand ils sont en fin de
mandat et ça c'est vrai au niveau
fédéral et dans tous les états donc à
chaque fois qu'il eut la moratoire sur
la peine de mort c'est parce que le
gouverneur en place savais qu'il
n'allait pas se représenter et il a mis
en place la première pierre c'est à dire
le moratoire est donc on va quand même
pour des mauvaises raisons mais pour des
bonnes au sens de l'histoire c'est ce
que vous me disiez c'est important que
je comprends à quel point on est choqués
nous européens de la vieille europe de
l'idée de l'argument de ça coûte cher
donc il faut l'abolir pour autant il
faut faut aussi allons regarder que les
états unis aux etats-unis le signifiant
principal la notion par laquelle on
aborde un peu tout dans le quotidien
c'est le dollar et l'argent donc
ça leur parle aussi alors par contre
c'est à double tranchant parce que
certains disent il faut abandonner tout
ce système de recours et faire en sorte
que la peine de mort coûte moins cher de
façon à pouvoir l'appliquer plus
facilement donc c'est un argument qui
double qui et qui aussi quel état il est
fait cas c'est assez dangereux les
administrations républicaines il ya eu
des lois
justement qui réduisent le nombre de
recours en habeas corpus un mot nous
avançons dans ce débat un mot sur les
noyaux durs de la peine de mort dans le
monde
oui il ya de quoi faire la différence
entre parce que la différence majeure
c'est que les états unis sont une
démocratie et appliquent la peine de
mort ailleurs dans les régimes
autoritaires ont peut-être un mot au
moins sur la complexité
oui mais effectivement il faut pas les
oublier un surtout le japon quand même
être régulièrement lire dans l'arrêt de
bord c'est la lapidation
là on peut dans ce cas oui bon d'accord
elle a largement la grande maison
que des alors le problème principal que
pose il faut quand même distingué pays
par pays est pas une chose un pays en
guerre comme c'est le cas en il assure
qu une théocratie enfin bon tout ça est
très différent mais le problème
principal auquel on se heurte dans le
noyau dur c'est la question du secret en
chine notamment c'est ça qu'on ne sait
pas aux états unis ce que disait à nos
gaillards en appui sur le site on a même
des sites de prison c'est extrêmement
clair on peut savoir à la minute près ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis en chine on
ne sait pas il ya tout un discours en ce
moment des politiques chinois autour
d'eux mais vous voyez maintenant on est
devenus très très bon avec la question
de la peine de mort on publie ce n'est
pas vrai ce n'est pas accessible tout
les voilà qu'en plus le show de lempire
d'autrefois
oui oui tout à fond aussi démocratie
c'est extrêmement difficile de parler
d'aborder ces sujets là extrêmement
difficile de faire dans l'immédiat on
connaît les exécutions le lendemain la
famille aussi à taiwan en oublie taïwan
aussi dans les démocraties un taïwanais
même chose nous avons vécu oui raconté
cette anecdote l'otan va nous manquer
mais un témoin salaire grâce vraiment
très très difficile la coalition
mondiale tenait son comité de pilotage à
taiwan en avril dernier et donc que nous
étions 20 bain et 20 personnes du comité
de pilotage nous avons été reçus par
toutes les autorités notamment le
président de la république prendre une
très grande pompe une partie avec les
médias est parti sans média un moment
donné on lui a posé la question de
savoir pourquoi depuis 2008 il n'avait
jamais exercé son droit de grâce c'est
la seule question à laquelle il n'a pas
répondu
c'était le mardi vendredi matin chacun
est rentré chez soi et il ya eu six
exécutions du jeudi au vendredi
est-ce que malgré ça et on finira là
dessus
l'abolition universelle c'est un rêve ou
c'est par eve tangible
une espérance pour laquelle il faut se
battre avec une grande détermination et
avec encore une fois des motifs fondés
sur la relativité de notre condition et
d'ignorance où nous sommes nous mêmes de
ce que nous sommes capables de faire le
meilleur et le pire
vous pensez que dans un futur proche
l'amérique ce ne sera pas le fait d'un
seul homme
on l'a dit parce qu'il ya plusieurs
états c'est très compliqué ça pourra
peut être comme en france mais
l'amérique tend vers une abolition suite
sur cinq ans il y aussi la cour suprême
la cour suprême est revenue en 76 sur
une déclaration d'inconstitutionnalité
mais petit à petit elle limite le champ
d'application de la peine de mort elle a
exclu les mineurs au moment des faits
elle exclut les handicapés mans et puis
récemment une décision qui a fait
beaucoup de bruit a été très critiquée
malgré une majorité dite de droite à la
cour elle a dit que quelqu'un qui avait
commis un viol
même sur mineurs ne pouvaient pas être
passible de la peine de mort donc on se
rend compte que petit à petit elle ne
veut pas ou ne peut pas compte tenu de
sa composition déclaré la peine de mort
inconstitutionnelle tout le temps mais
elle limite le champ d'application
il est auditeur abolitionniste augmente
aux etats unis le nombre d'exécutions
diminue c'est vrai qu'on va pas attendre
je pense aux etats unis une disparition
un peu radicale comme en france avec une
seule loi d'abord yab gaïa 32 états qui
la maintiennent encore par contre ça
disparaît un peu sur la pointe des pieds
donc il ya cet optimisme se retient ce
rythme là alors espérons merci à tous
d'être venus sur ce plateau votre
documentaire et semaine prochaine sera
consacrée aux 30 ans de la marche des
beurs suivie d'un débat avec benoît
duquesne
moi je retrouve je vous retrouve dans 15
jours pour un débat consacré à silvio
berlusconi a très vite sur public sénat
ouf